es ist natürlich wichtig dass wir uns
politisch beteiligen das ist richtig so
aber
ja wie soll ich denn überhaupt mich
beteiligen wenn all das was ich sage was
mich stört sofort öffentlich platt
gemacht wird von
meiner großen Social Media Blase wenn
ich nur unbequeme Fragen stelle oder
ungepasste angepasste Meinung habe und
eben nicht die Power das eben so rüber
zu bringen mit alles was ich sage
einfach in eine Schublade gesteckt wird
und ich mundtot gemacht werde und so
viel Beispiele gibt es wie also kann ich
gar nicht eine aufzählen aber nur ein
paar wer corona-maßnahmen kritisiert und
sie in Frage gestellt ist sofort ein
Querdenker wer fragt ob die Millionen
Flüchtlinge die sie hier sind in diesem
an sich wirklich integrieren können oder
integrieren wollen ist sofort ein
rechtsextremer oder deutsch-national
oder ausländerfeindlich wer Fragen hat
warum die Beziehung von Bürgergeld
eigentlich ne so viel verdienen oder
ungefähr so viel verdienen die Leute ja
hart arbeiten ist sofort asozial oder
antisozial oder hat was gegen diejenigen
die bedürftig sind und Wasserhahn
empfindet wenn man diese Kunstpause
macht im Gendern bei Politiker innen der
ist sowieso gegen Frauen und homophob
das genauso und alles Mögliche was man
sich dann noch vorstellen kann das
mittlerweile doch so dass Kritik
verächtlich gemacht wird wenn sie
wirkliche Beweggründe hat auf die
Politik zum Teil keine Antworten hat
oder keine Antworten geben will und
stattdessen wird die Meinung des Gegners
diskreditiert und mit Hilfe manchmal
sogar von Gesetzen her tatsächlich auch
diese Meinung mundtot gemacht und das
darf nicht sein und das ein
grundlegendes Problem für Politik und
das müssen wir ändern wir brauchen also
den Mut derjenigen die sich artikulieren
wollen sich zu artikulieren und was zu
sagen und auch in die Politik zu gehen
und nicht nur in den extremen die diese
Haltung wiedergeben Herr Stahl sind ja
jemand der viel kritisiert werden
sie dafür auch diffamiert
grundsätzlich macht er seit 9 Jahren
machen wir da einfach kurz wieder in
Deutschland ist immer der gefährlicher
der die Missstände anspricht als der die
mich gerne macht und zu beantworten hat
und es ist einfach jemanden zu schaffen
und sich in Dreck zu ziehen damit der
Mund gemacht wird dann hat man wird mir
alle gemacht ich bin seit 9 Jahren dabei
man wollte mich in die Ecke drücken in
die Ecke drücken Nazi es ist oder
populistisch ich sage immer konkret
wohin wurden sie die Farbe also alles
mögliche da wenn du dich dazu geäußert
hast dann hieß das auf einmal ja du
musst ja recht sein dann hast du hast
doch noch Stahl du hast also bestimmt
weniger zum Beispiel vor kurzem erst
wieder nehmen wir den Fall Ludwigshafen
Ludwigshafen ich habe mich hingestellt
und habe gesagt ein Video gemacht
übrigens die Eltern und die Schwester
der Opfer haben mir geschrieben sich bei
mir benannt und ich gesagt dass ich dass
ich es beschämend finde ein beschämen
finde dass man diesen Menschen die hier
zu Tode gekommen sind die man hier
zerstückelt hat dass man den nicht
kontrolliert erste Woche später ist Frau
Feser der Meinung da mal kurz eine
Wurzer heben wenn es aber jemand trifft
der woanders herkommt der
Migrationshintergrund dann benutzt man
das sofort wieder mit dem rechten Auge
und schiebt die Nummer in die mit der
Nazi um so wenn du das dann aber
anspricht ich mache dir schon seit
Jahren meine Kinder sind polnisch meine
Freundin ist Muslimen also die können
sich Ihre Nazi könnte so zu entschieden
aber das haben sie natürlich probiert
entscheiden immer wenn die Politik nicht
mehr keine Argumente hat kommt sie mit
der naziole oder mit dem Populismus
Nummer aber anstatt etwas sich mal mit
dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen beste
Beispiel die Menschen hatten fragen sie
haben bestimmte Dinge fragen wollte weil
ihr Körper nein sie wurden sofort als
schwuppler Verschwörungstheorie drinnen
gestellt und wie kommt es jetzt raus
Lauterbach hast du nur nicht mit allem
die Wahl gesagt er hat sogar
veröffentlich gelogen aber jetzt redet
keiner irgendwie mehr darüber jetzt ist
es schon normal weil wir haben hier die
nächste Krise wir stolpern vor einem in
der nächsten das schöne ist ich bin ja
auch der Beweis dass man halt schon noch
seine Meinung sagen kann aber ich habe
natürlich auch nein stimmt man wird hier
darf ich sprechen man wird mich doch
nicht irgendwo hin holen z.B oder
irgendeiner zu diesem systemkonform
Firmen wo sie einfach wissen nee den
gehen wir keine Bühne hier kriegt man
eine Bühne und die Nutzung ich werde zum
Beispiel auch schon mal eingeladen
obwohl ich sehr hart gegen
corona-maßnahmen
so dann weißt du was Sie wollen
vielleicht kriege ich sie ja noch aber
ich will einfach sagen ich gebe Dir
Recht dass man halt dass man um und es
gibt ja mal wieder populäre Beispiel
Kimmich z.B geht aus dem Spiel raus hat
die schwitzt und man fragt ihn so
mittendrin und er hat einfach
öffentliche Antwort das sein Körper
sofort wurde Elsass Nena deine namens da
drin sofort geschafft man will ein
Exempel statuieren macht das Maul auf
und wir fangen an dich zu vernichten ich
frage hier einmal ich muss ja immer
kommt ich hatte auch ein Lernprozess
tatsächlich auch bei Corona und die war
auch für die Impfpflicht und habe mich
dann ja ich hatte auch einen
erweiterungserlebnis ganz kurz in
München tatsächlich da war ich im
letzten Winter da war eine Demo
eigentlich angesagt war aber verboten
gegen Corona stand all diese Wannen auf
dem Marienplatz ist ja so schöne Platz
mit dem Rathaus und die Leute dürften
nicht demonstrieren und standen mit
großem Abstand nebeneinander und dachte
was Murmeln die da bin hingegangen
murmelden sie das Vaterunser einfach als
als Zeichen dass sie zusammengehören und
als Protest weil Protest nicht möglich
war soweit waren wir da schon gekommen
und da habe ich gedacht das ist auch
nicht richtig
Herr Greber welche Rolle spielen denn
die Medien weil was Bela under und
Carsten Stahl angesprochen haben
vermutlich bemerken sie auch also ich
bemerke es auch sehr stark wenn man
allein auf Twitter unterwegs ist wie
sehr erlauben Medien Meinung und andere
Haltungen also die Medienlandschaft in
Deutschland finde ich ist da an diesem
ist da sehr problematisch an an dem
Punkt ich arbeite ja selbst bei Cicero
ich darf noch kurz
das ist ein ein politisches
Monatsmagazin was sich wieder da ist
aber nicht Angela Merkel die
migrationskirche Krise kehrt zurück das
ist eigentlich auch das Thema wo Cicero
damals auch so diesen Ruf bekommen hat
ein ein rechtes Magazin zu sein war dann
immer der Vorwurf also wir sind auf
jeden Fall konservativer als als andere
Zeitschriften aber nicht nur so oder auf
jeden Fall auch nicht schlimm nein aber
nur wollte ich kurz mit zur Verordnung
sagen aber das war damals die
flüchtlingskrise 2015/16 wo das glaube
ich auch anfing in Deutschland diese
Spaltung der persönlichen Meinung und
dass man bestimmte Meinungen die sogar
würde ich sagen fast zumindest fast
sogar eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
vertreten hat dass man die versucht hat
auszugrenzen und das hat zizeron sofern
auch erlebt dass wir innerhalb der
Medienbranche ich war damals noch nicht
dort ich habe es aber selbst gelesen
wurde Cicero schon versucht auszugrenzen
hat Gott sei nicht geklappt die
Verkaufszahlen sind aber gestiegen in
der Zeit ganz deutlich das zeigt ja aber
ja und das ist also ich glaube wir
Journalisten müssen den Mut haben dass
wir wenn wir
Themen anpacken die der Bevölkerung
einfach wichtig sind es ist auch immer
frage wie man sie anpackt also
ist gerade auch auf eins was von allen
Journalisten eigentlich fast deformiert
wurde die Bürger mögen manchmal andere
Sachen gerne als sie Journalisten ja und
da müssen wir uns mit auseinandersetzen
und wir müssen aber auch den Mut haben
das was Kollegen über uns denken und
schreiben auch nicht ganz ernst zu
nehmen das ist dann doch eine sehr
kleine